in all of my career and you asked me how
did i jump from one thing to the other
it's just that one person that opened
the door and showed me that there might
be an opportunity that i didn't think
about and there might be a network or a
thread that i need to pick up
so this is what the cicc's strengths
lies in uh this is where we can
uh provide those platforms for those
that are in the other side of the world
um
to get access to the u.s market
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet sharon
vannik shawn is the executive director
of the california israel chamber of
commerce the cicc
where she brings a remarkable 20 years
career with significant expertise in
international business and marketing
throughout her career sharon showed an
enterprising attitude from the start in
1997 she moved to south korea where she
started her long career in a
traditionally male dominated technical
fields of infrastructure and homeland
security she was asked to become the
first foreign ceo of the fast-growing
burma china and brought the company to
be a leader in water works
infrastructure in the entire southeast
asia she then worked with the us army
border control and highly secured
facilities to create enhance and
implement advanced solutions to existing
and future problems
during 2008 to 2010 chiron held vice
president homeland security and
infrastructure position in bdo i2i which
is part of the bdo israel consulting
firm and focused on the indian market
sharon vannik welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm very well thank
you thank you for having me
thank you so much for joining me you're
in california now right
correct i'm in san francisco california
all right that makes a lot of sense
because you're the executive director of
the california israel chamber of
commerce you're going to be telling me
all about what that means and i'm deeply
deeply curious
about about your role there and your
work there but your journey is just
mind-boggling if i try to list it it's
gonna take up the whole 20 minutes and
but you know you spend some time in asia
and china moving to the united states
working with the us army border control
homeland security a adjunct professor
then in business school and then on to
and now being the executive director of
the israel chamber of commerce i have to
understand a little bit about your
journey and i want you to take me all
the way back to your job interview on a
flight to china how how did that what
happened there
oh wow okay so you're taking me back
some 20 20 plus years um when i was in
china and i was volunteering
to organize a business delegation that
came with president herzog
they came to china just to explore
what the possibilities are and we are
looking at
1998.
um
and at the end of the the last day of
the delegation i was you know i was
going through the different business
people all of them were men of obviously
and i shake their hands and i say you
know i hope you enjoy it and i hope that
you you know you go back home with a lot
of opportunities and if you ever look
for someone on the ground
i'm here
and you know i go around and i shake
their hands and one of them
he was he was just an amazing person um
a board of the head of the board of
directors of an israeli company and he
told me sharon i'm really impressed with
all the work that you've done and i see
how you manage with the chinese and you
speak the language and everything and if
you ever look for a job
come and talk to me
and you know like in the stories they
turn around and they walk to the plane
and the plan left shanghai and actually
had a stopover in a different city in
china
so
i turned back and i'm thinking in my
head what should i do i have potentially
you know a job interview
so i pick up the phone and i call one of
the security details of the president
and i ask him do you have a room on the
plan for me
so he makes something he makes some you
know some calls and he checks and he
said well can you be in two hours in a
different you know in that different uh
city
i rush home i pack a bag literally just
an overnight bag
and i get to the to the airport and i
get on the fly you know on the airplanes
and i sit next to that business person
his name is yuda baja and i tell him
here i am i came for the interview and
that was it wow so um so that's how i
got my first job because he he looked at
me and he was puzzled and he said okay
you are a go-getter and that's exactly
what we need
and
that opened so many doors for me
um and it showed me i was 26 i lived in
china i never really had a real job
before that
um
and they gave me an opportunity
and that changed my life it changed my
life in so many ways because it taught
me that
if you want something
there is no wall between me and what i
want and
and you need to believe in people and
you know when somebody opens a crack on
the door
if that's what you want
you just need to burst in
um i love it i love it so this is this
is my first
actually that was my first and last job
interview ever
i'm not i'm not even surprised i have to
say walk me through with some of the
other milestones and and how you
you know one of the things that
fascinated me most when i when i look at
your journey from
an entrepreneurial perspective is you
know different things that you've gotten
to experience not just in the different
verticals but also in the different
types of roles that you had in the
different you know the different
locations with the different people
was this a was this you know is
something that you that you that you
wanted was this something that you
aspired to from an early age that you're
gonna be moving around and doing all
these crazy things because you know most
people they don't go
between so many different careers
to be honest no
when i was a kid you know i grew up in a
small town in israel
a hole in the wall as we say
i didn't think about
you know traveling the world
i had a normal childhood
and when
when i was thinking
what do i want to do when i grew up i
knew it somehow connected to business
that's all that i knew
and um when i enrolled to university
what i wanted to study was just an
advanced uh study so which was only a
master a degree on the invest
one
and i had to pick something for my
bachelor degree
and i remember i remember as it was
yesterday back in the days we had thick
book of you know all the courses and all
the majors you have in university and i
was going flipping through the to the
book
with my parents and my dad he said well
you know i have a feeling that the
future is in asia
so if you want to learn something which
is completely different
something of interest something that
won't be like everybody else go and
study about asia
so i spent my bachelor degree
um you know in east uh east asian
studies and
it opened a whole new world for me and i
knew that i wanted to move to asia
because you know you spent three years
you break your teeth learning chinese
korean
and and you know through those years in
university through my bachelor degree
i i just became so curious again it's
the other side of the world there's
nothing of what i saw again we are
talking about 25 years ago there weren't
that many foreigners in china you know
in israel
you know outside of the typical israeli
and i knew that once i graduate this is
where i want to go because it's like
reading a you know an adventure book or
you read harry potter and you want to be
part you want to be immersed in that
magic world
and that's what my bachelor degree was
for me it was just a fairy tale and i
wanted to know what this is in reality
so
wow once i landed in asia and it wasn't
china i landed in korea um
it just fascinated me and i said to
myself um i i want to i want to learn
more i want to
there you know israel will stay the same
more or less
but this is a whole new word for me
and i'm very lucky i found a life
partner that shared that um you know
curiosity
about different people different culture
different parts of the world
so
we made a decision early on that
as long as we have the strength
and the means
we want to travel the world that we want
to experience
incredible i wanna i wanna fast forward
a little bit for the interest of time i
i'm i'm so sad to be skipping over what
some incredible stories uh that you've
had in the us with the us army the
border control and the homeland security
but
today you know executive director of the
california israel chamber of commerce
you know obviously there's california
there's israel there's commerce there's
a chamber in there what what what is
this what what is this
okay so the california israel chamber of
commerce
known as the cicc is actually an
industry-based organization that was
founded here in california some 20-plus
years ago by a group of israeli business
people
that wanted to do what we know nowadays
as you know as the linkedin and social
media and all of this they didn't have
it so they literally created an excel
sheet with the people that they know
so you know the six uh
six degrees of separation they wanted to
to see how they can expand their network
so this is how it all started and really
as an
organization
um our mission is to create
opportunities for different stakeholders
in the industry and there are different
industries that the organization is part
of to meet their counterparts on the
other side of the world and we do it
through
you know delegations and and pitch
events and networking and conferences
and so on and so on and we also work
with companies as you know one-on-one
trying to help them to reach their own
goals and each company have different
different goals right one wants to raise
funds ones want to
get the network get the branding
establish their operation and so on and
so forth so we work bottom up with
really early stage startups trying to
help them to understand what the u.s
market looks like
because some some industries are very
similar in israel and and here in in the
us or primarily in california but others
they have completely different structure
and just to name for example the
healthcare
market or the agriculture market that's
being structured differently so we
really dive into those industries um we
also work top down means we work with
big corporates and we help them with
technology scouting in israel
and we have a representative in israel
we have the office here in california we
work all over california so our focus
the fact that i live in san francisco it
doesn't mean that we focus only on
silicon valley area
right how do you know if you're doing a
good job so what what are some you know
the kpis of the organization or how do
you keep yourself in check because
obviously there's so much happening
between israel and california
specifically and you know especially as
we've seen in the last few years and now
honestly after covet not everything has
to be done in person or you know in
moving between places now a lot of
things are done digitally
how do you know whether you know the the
this organization is doing what it's
supposed to be doing
okay number one we've been around for
over 20 years and the world changes and
there are so many different
new ways to network
and the fact that the organization is
still here and still thriving and
operating and we have our community of
over 10 000 people um means that
probably the organization is doing
something right this is number one
um
number two
um you know
if you try to look at the organization
you know the website or social media and
so on you won't see us very active like
other influencers
and
companies get keep getting to us it's a
word of thumb so someone and you know
people change their career they move
from one startup to another from one
company to the other
and we get so many times
uh founders that come to us and say you
know my biz dev person used to work for
that company and he worked with you five
years ago four years ago or 15 years ago
so it's really the word of mouth so
companies are coming back to us
entrepreneurs come back to us when they
are in their new journey um so
only these two show us that we are
probably doing something right
right and so as you're thinking through
you know the last even the last five or
ten years what have you observed you
know even just looking back at what's
been happening between israel and
california or what what we can expect
for the future
where what inflection point are we in
right now because it feels like some
inflection point it feels like things
are changing and things aren't the same
as what they were before
wow um
you know you talk about
changes and things that are not the same
i feel that a lot is is the same
actually
i feel that you know
um so when we look at the business
community the israeli business community
in california
uh we can divide it to two groups there
is the group of people that come here
just for a few years and then they go
back they come here either on the
contract or they come for advanced you
know postdoc in different universities
and then they move back so those are the
the temporary uh you know people in the
community but then we have those
entrepreneurs that came here i don't
know how many years ago they came with a
company
and they stayed they started their own
business their own company they um
they um
got some some
strength
and and experience from living in
california
and
now they became local businesses uh
local startups some of them are more
successful than others then they invest
back in the community and when i said
they invest back in the communities not
necessarily in the israeli community
they invest back in the california
community they they provide jobs uh they
give back to the community
and they they became part of the of the
ecosystem here so
um
and and we also feel that there are more
and more companies that are curious and
and more people
that uh um want to learn more about
israel and what israel have to give
right
so
i don't see that we i don't think we got
to a peak i think that there is so much
more to be done
right now does your engagement with the
companies maintain after once you make
these introductions and create those
synergies because a lot of it is going
to be company to company company to
employees company to employers
where is the california israel chamber
of commerce positioned you know once
those those walls are broken down
initially
well to be honest with you i think that
nowadays most of uh um
most of our impact is really with the
early stage companies
because once a company already have you
know a round or maybe two rounds of
funding because they have network they
have customers they have their links
um
yeah i don't want to say they don't need
us anymore and you know you mentioned
covet and we were thriving during
covet because we
we can give the access of knowledge we
can give the access to the network we
can provide access to funding so really
with the early stage
companies i don't want to say the
clueless entrepreneurs that just dream
about the us they want to come to the
market but really with those that need
that person to open the door and if i go
back to my own story in all of my career
and you asked me how did i jump from one
thing to the other it's just that one
person that opened the door and showed
me that there might be an opportunity
that i didn't think about and there
might be a network or thread that i need
to pick up
so this is what the cicc's strengths
lies in uh this is where we can
uh provide those platforms for those
that are in the other side of the world
um to get access to the u.s market
right now what what happens you know
let's have an early stage company and i
and i reach out and and now i'm looking
for some assistance what are what are
sort of the steps that you would take
with me so that you are best equipped to
to help me and then sort of how does
this whole process look like
all right so first of all we have a
questionnaire that we really sit with
the the founder or the business person
and we try to understand
what the company is doing where they are
at in terms of their product of their
strategy development you know
fundraising and so on once we understand
that we we really ask hard questions
what do they need and sometimes we get
oh we need to fundraise we need clients
we need market access we want to launch
our business and we say okay hold on
let's see what is more urgent
where you'll be able to get you know
fast results
what should be the process so we really
break down to the different processes
and we tell them if they want to come to
the us there are three foundations that
they have to to have there is the legal
foundation there is the tax foundation
and there is the people
strategy
so right
all of which are none of which are
simple exactly so we we sit with them
and then we bring experts so if they
need legal advice we provide them legal
consultancy if they need tax advisory we
work with organizations and companies
that have both israeli and
and you know u.s
establishments so we provide them
different consultancy along the way and
then we we we and we try to understand
okay you they're looking for fun
fundraising okay
you're an early stage or a later stage
what exactly is your um you know
industry that you are in then we go back
to our database
and our database has
tons of names so we go and sort we're
trying to find those you know if it's a
vc or angels or whatever that they're
looking for and then we approach them we
sit together with the company we write
the pitch together
because
we can advocate for the for the company
you know
to a certain limit we i also want to
mention that in the cicc we work with
advisory boards so we have people from
the industry that volunteer with the cia
they're all volunteers and they're
coming from different walks of life so
if we're looking at our med tech uh
committee some of them are doctors some
of them works in uh some of them working
in hospitals um
some of them work with um
some themselves are entrepreneurs and so
on if it's our cyber security advisory
committee we have csos we have investors
we have
uh people in
fraud protection and so on so
once we get a company that we work with
a new member in our
community
i actually take all that information and
i hand it to the advisory committee and
typically we have someone within that
committee that will say oh you know what
i can open my rolodex and help them and
help these specific companies so this is
the process this is how we work with
them
and hopefully we can we can help them
i love it i love it and sharon there's
so much that we can talk about i already
have about 15 more questions that that
come up but but i know and i'm always so
so that i called this show 20 minute
leaders and not 30 or 40 minute leaders
what would be two or three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um everybody say i'm stubborn
okay
um i'm very curious in my first you know
in my personality and i'm very
open-minded so i would say those are
four words because open-minded are two
but i think you you can't be
successful and yes i did not i did not
fund uh i'm
a company i didn't invent anything but
i'm a very curious and open-minded
person and i'm very stubborn about
things that i want to accomplish and
achieve
um
so when i was asked if i can stand in a
classroom
um
and be an adjunct professor in in
english
i didn't hesitate i said yes i would i
never stand in front of people uh you
know in that capacity i was never a
teacher and an educator
um
but i said yes and i said you know what
worst case scenario they fire me after
one semester
yes it lasts a few years but
that exactly was just about to say that
that didn't really quite turn out that
way but
but
so definitely share an incredible
journey thank you so much for sharing
this time with me i can't wait to share
this with the world
and really really inspiring and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you
[Music]